es ist nicht nur anders ist wird er
natürlich in diskussion mit den ländern
von uns schon seit monaten interessiert
wir haben aber auch zu gestern ich war
gestern auch im haushaltsausschuss jetzt
zu verschiedenen themen da auch noch mal
einen bericht über sand jetzt auf bundes
länder bezogen was die zahl der nach den
finanz volumina jedenfalls geschaffenen
intensivbetten angeht und die länder
müssen natürlich auch ein nachweis
erbringen über die geschaffenen betten
idealerweise und auch das ist unser
ansinnen krankenhaus scharf also auf das
einzelne krankenhaus bezogen aber wissen
sie jetzt auch eine sehr grundsätzliche
frage des föderalen miteinanders ich
kann mich an die gesetzgebung noch sehr
gut erinnern
das ist ja alles muss immer man sich
noch mal ändern nicht alles über ein
jahr her
die gesetzgebung zu der intensivbetten
förderung es gab den beschluss von bund
und ländern
die intensiv kapazitäten in deutschland
verdoppeln zu wollen
ich weiß noch wie auch unter anderem
richtigerweise finanzminister scholz
sehr darauf gedrängt hat dass wir klare
zielvorgaben machen das entstehen soll
und dafür klare regeln da sind dann
haben wir ins gesetz den ländern den
auftrag gegeben diese zu verwalten und
zu zuweisen und ich müsste auch im
föderalen miteinander von bund und
ländern davon ausgehen können und dürfen
das wenn länder investitionszuschüsse
ausreichend eingebunden sind an
bestimmte bedingungen bisschen dass wir
eine debatte hatten lokale oder high
care und wer sehr gibt tage gesagt haben
high care also höherer standard an
intensivbetten ausstattung dass dann die
vom bund über die länder verwalteten und
zugewiesenen daneben auch ordnungsgemäß
verwaltet und zugewiesen werden so ist
das in der föderalen struktur übrigens
nicht nur in der pandemie sondern
grundsätzlich dass nicht wenige
förderprogramme daneben auch über die
länder in der verwaltung umgesetzt
werden und deswegen kann und soll das
alles natürlich auch nach gehalten und
mit transparenz versehen werden und das
wird zug um zug der bundesrechnungshof
erkennt im übrigen ja auch an
das in einer pandemischen notsituation
eben auch zügig hat gehandelt werden
müssen wenn ich genau gelesen haben nach
einer nachfrage an haben wir auch noch
in dem bericht des rechnungshofes auch
von einem schreiben des lka an das
gesundheitsministerium vom 11 januar
diesen jahres die rede wo es darum geht
dass sie sagen dass manche kliniken
möglicherweise künstlich niedrige zahlen
von intensivbetten melden um an
zuschüsse zu kommen
sie berichten davon mehreren e mails und
telefonanrufen die das al-kaida-
bekommen hat dann zieht es ungefähr
quantifizieren um wie viel ihrer
einschätzung nach die intensiv die freie
intensivbetten zahl künstlich nach unten
gerechnet worden ist also da muss ich
zunächst mal sagen dass ich weder den
bericht des rechnungshofs kenne noch
noch mich jetzt an einen bericht
erinnern kann werden wir prüfen können
wir gerne nachliefern
aber momentan will ich dazu die
sprachfähig wir sind bild und wie ihr
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren